♪
>> Laura: WELCOME BACK TO
THE INGRAHAM ANGLE.
WE CONTINUE OUR DISCUSSION
WITH THREE VERY SPECIAL
WOMEN ANGEL MOMS.
MICHELLE ROOT, MAURY MALONE
AND SABINE DURBIN.
ALL OF THEM HAVE LOST FAMILY
MEMBERS, SONS TO ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT CRIME.
FOREVER SEPARATED FROM THEM.
SABINE, YOU SAID THE KILLER
OF YOUR SON, HOW LONG IN
JAIL?
>> 35 DAYS.
>> Laura: 35 DAYS.
>> 35 WHOLE DAYS.
HIS MOTHER WAS PROBABLY
DRYING REAL HARD.
>> Laura: PAUL BEGALA SAID
THIS TODAY ABOUT THE TRUMP
MEETING WITH ALL OF YOU.
LET'S WATCH.
>> HE KNOWS WHAT HE IS
DOING.
HE IS TAKING THIS RAW, REAL
PAIN THESE POOR FAMILIES ARE
SUFFERING WHICH IS AUTHENTIC
AND POLITICIZING IT.
RIGHT?
IT IS MONSTROUS TO TAKE
THESE FOLKS' PAIN AND USE TO
TO TRY TO DIVIDE AMERICA.
>> Laura: MICHELLE?
>> I DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW TO
RESPOND TO THAT THAT IS SO
ANGRY BECAUSE OUR VOICES
NEED TO BE HEARD.
OUR CHILDREN'S VOICES NEED
TO BE HEARD.
WE NEED TO HEAR THE OTHER
SIDE OF THIS.
>> Laura: YOUR DAUGHTER IS
BEAUTIFUL.
YOUR SON IS BEAUTIFUL.
>> VERY ANGRY.
VERY ANGRY.
>> Laura: MAUREEN?
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S
RIDICULOUS.
I WAS SPEAKING OUT AGAINST
THIS LONG BEFORE TRUMP
ANNOUNCED HE WAS EVEN
RUNNING TO BE PRESIDENT.
OUR CHILDREN NEED TO HAVE A
VOICE AND WE ARE TRYING TO
RAISE AWARENESS AND EDUCATE
PEOPLE AND PREVENT FUTURE
DEATHS.
>> Laura: THIS IS KATHY
GRIFFIN, SABINE, SO-CALLED
COMEDIAN.
MESSAGE TO THE PARENTS WHO
ARE ON STAGE WITH TRUMP AT
THIS PRESS CONFERENCE.
I'M SO SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS
BUT THE MAN YOU ARE STANDING
WITH, TRUMP, COULD GIVE TWO
S, SHE CAN'T TWEET WITHOUT
SWEARING HE IS USING YOU FOR
PROPAGANDA, SABINE.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO SAY TO
KATHY GRIFFIN.
>> I WANT HER TO MEET ME
FACE TO FACE AND TELL ME HOW
THIS IS PROPAGANDA.
THIS IS MY SON'S ASHES IN
HERE.
HE IS THE ONLY MAN THAT
BROUGHT THIS TO THE
SHE NEEDS TO GO INTO A
LITTLE BACK ALLEY AND
ENTERTAIN THE TWO PEOPLE
THAT ARE STILL FOLLOWING
HER.
SHE HAS NO -- SHE JUST HAS
NO GROUND, SHE HAS NO SOUL
AND NO HEART.
I PRAY TO GOD SHE NEVER
KNOWS THIS FEELING.
>> Laura: MICHELLE HE WILL
VALUE IS
MILUE IS
MITCE IS
MITCHEIS
MITCHELL SALVADORRAN MAN CROSSIN
MITCHELL SALVADORRAN MAN CROSSIG
MITCHELL SALVADORRAN MAN CROSSIT
MITCHELL SALVADORRAN MAN CROSSIE
MITCHELL SALVADORRAN MAN CROSSIB
MITCHELL SALVADORRAN MAN CROSSIR
MITCHELL SALVADORRAN MAN CROSSIE
MITCHELL SALVADORRAN MAN CROSSI.
>> A MAN AND DAUGHTER WERE
ARRESTED IN TEXAS BY BORDER
AGENTS.
I WAS TOLD MY DAUGHTER AND I
HAD TO GET ON DIFFERENT
BUSES BECAUSE THERE WASN'T
ENOUGH ROOM, HE SAYS.
BUFF WHEN THEY WERE DRIVEN
TO McALLEN WHERE MANY MY
GRANTS ARE BEING PROCESSED
6-YEAR-OLD MAYBELLINE WAS
SUDDENLY NOWHERE TO BE SEEN.
I SAID WHERE IS MY DAUGHTER?
DON'T SEPARATE US.
DON'T LET US IN BUT DON'T
RIP US APART, HE SAYS.
>> Laura: EMOTIONAL, YOUR
REACTION.
>> I WAS RIPPED APART FROM
SARA AND YOU'RE ACCOUNTABLE
FOR YOUR ACTION.
YOU ARE THE ONE THAT CROSSED
THAT BORDER ILLEGALLY WITH
YOUR CHILD.
YOU WERE NOT LOOKING OUT FOR
>> I CONCUR WITH MICHELLE.
WE DIDN'T HAVE A CHOICE.
OUR CHILDREN WERE RIPPED
FROM OUR LIVES.
THEY HAVE A CHOICE.
>> Laura: WOMEN ACROSS THE